all right before we get started today i
just wanted to take a moment and
give a big shout out to our sponsor
today the great courses
plus the great courses plus is a place
where you can go to learn
uh about just about anything pretty much
anything yeah we've been doing a lot of
learning over the
uh covet 19 uh social distancing
pandemic lockdown
we're not alone there i think a lot of
people have you've had a lot of time to
sit on your computer on on your handheld
and watch
great courses plus i've been learning a
little bit about photography
that's been helping me along with my
dslr what have you been
checking out well i've been using great
courses plus for
prepping for this show which is uh so
it's really coming in handy well i mean
we
we talked about it before with bill nye
and then of course this show
today we're talking about life outside
of this planet so why not go to
life in our universe with professor
laird close and you're learning about
astrobiology which is going to be a big
topic what we're discussing today so
basically for me the great courses plus
has been a way to prep for the show
because we're often talking to super
smart thought leaders and professors
which we are today wow it's how smart
people prepare for their shows the great
courses plus
they've got thousands of lectures on
almost any topic imaginable from
philosophy
to astrophysics to learning to speak
spanish and
new courses are added all the time so
there's something for everyone plus
every course is presented like richard
said by subject matter experts from top
universities and institutions
and you can watch or listen from your
phone or tv
with the great courses plus app at any
time
from anywhere in the world make the most
of your time
keep learning with the great courses
plus they're offering fans of this show
an amazing deal an entire month of
access
for free free this limited time offer
won't last sign up today to get started
go to thegreatcoursesplus.com slash what
if
don't wait the great courses plus dot
com
slash what if once again it's the great
courses plus
dot com slash what if slash what if
and it's gonna come in handy but also as
we're talking about
you're gonna need to learn a little to
be able to follow this particular show
today because we're talking about
something that's pretty far
out there but you're in good hands
because our guests today will also be
somebody that will be able to help us
look smarter by the end of today's show
amazing let's get to the show
well it was about four years or even
more that much work that
led to the announcement it started out
around 2015 2016
with a crazy idea by professor jane
grieves from the uk
she really went out on a limb and she
wanted to search for signs of life on
venus
now that may seem all good and legit to
you but it's very fringe
honestly searching for life searching
for signs of life on venus because it's
so harsh
so harsh for any kind of life as we know
it it's really really out there
[Music]
so pete it wouldn't be the first time
we've discussed the possibility of
extraterrestrial life on this show it
seems like every week we're discussing
the people
well people love it but also there's
something in the air i love it
and there's news about it but then you
hear the recent
news the breaking news about potential
life
on the planet venus what did you make of
that when you first heard about that
well it certainly got that
wow factor because this is the first
discovery and in a planet
right next to us incredible uh people
have always talked about
you know search for extraterrestrial
life and oh we think this could happen
over here or this might be happening on
this exoplanet
we don't know but this is almost proof
right next door yes so on a planet
that's
that's primarily not known for
like we talk about sending probes to
mars all the time we talk about
exoplanets to your point
we don't talk about going to venus
because i'll tell you why yes
you can't go to venus because it's uh
temperatures get up to 880 degrees
fahrenheit so the russians have sent
things to venus in uh before
but the temperature's hot enough to melt
lead so you land on there
you can probably get i think they got
maybe 50 minutes of transmission from
venus and then so if you're gonna spend
all that money to go to venus
it's for a probe if you land the probe
it's for a probe that's only gonna last
for about an hour
and then it's gone so for those people
that don't know
because again uh you might have just
heard the word venus or life
or whatever but it's again
it's not necessarily the discovery of
e.t the extraterrestrial
but it's significant for those people
who don't know what is the story
essentially yeah if you were
under a rock this week or only reading
the first 10 stories of your instagram
uh you probably missed uh any of the
myriad of headlines
on saying such things as astronomers may
have found
signature of life on venus scientists
detect possible signs of life on venus
phosphine
detected in the atmosphere on venus
possible sign of life will nasa choose
venus mission after phosphine discovery
that would make sense it's actually a
shorter trip than mars
it is but uh i'm not the person to
answer that question
well i would and no disrespect to you or
to me
i am also not the person that answered
that question we need an astronomer we
need an astronomer
pete who is one of the foremost
astronomers in the world around this
type of stuff well i think you know that
that's our guest here on the show today
professor sarah seeger
today's guest is one of the foremost
astronomers
on venus or any other planet and
co-author of the nature astronomy paper
that's causing all the fuss
mit professor sarah seeger she was born
and grew up in toronto canada among her
first memories
was a trip to a star party with her
father to see the moon
through a telescope she is the class of
1941
professor of planetary science professor
of physics and professor of aeronautics
and
astronautics at mit her past research
is credited with laying the foundation
for the field
of exoplanet atmospheres while her
current research
focuses on exoplanet atmospheres and the
future search for signs of life by way
of
atmospheric biosignature gases before
joining mit in 2007 professor seger
spent
four years on the senior research staff
at the carnegie institution of
washington
proceeded by three years at the
institution for advanced study
in princeton new jersey her phd is from
harvard university
and her bsc from the university of
toronto
among other accolades professor seger is
a member of the national
academy of sciences and a 2013 macarthur
fellow
professor seeger welcome to what if
discuss thanks for joining us
thanks for having me first question how
much have you slept in the last seven
days
well i have time to sleep but i haven't
been able to sleep
because my mind is just spinning with a
million ideas
is it being it's been crazy busy for you
though right mostly getting
ready for the press conference that we
had a couple days ago
and just answering millions of questions
like it's incredible
the response we've had the interest from
all kinds of
journalists and programs all around the
world yeah it was really it was covered
everywhere which is great to see because
peter and i talk about
this on the show occasionally where
we'll see what we think is a massive
development
you know about life and whatever it'll
be like the seventh story
on cnn or or whatever so this really did
get i think the
the appropriate level of coverage
great as to be expected you didn't just
stumble into this this wasn't just an
overnight uh
discovery uh the team came at it from
all angles
just to make sure that everything was
right i mean literally looking at it
from different telescopes to uh to prove
uh your theories make sure that you were
seeing what you're seeing maybe talk
about this process
sure well it was about four years or
even more that much work that
led to the announcement it started out
around 2015 2016
with a crazy idea by professor jane
grieves from the uk
she really went out on a limb and she
wanted to search for signs of life on
venus
now that may seem all good and legit to
you but it's very fringe
honestly searching for life searching
for signs of life on venus because it's
so harsh
so harsh for any kind of life as we know
it it's really really out there
and she cased the scientific literature
she dug deep and
looked for what gas would be suitable
and i'm so impressed with her because
she came across these really obscure
papers on phosphine
a gas that is not really made by
anything other than humans and it's
associated with bacteria
in oxygen free environments now in the
meantime
my team had also found those obscure
papers because we're working on
the search for signs of life by way of
gases that don't belong
for actually exoplanets planets outside
of our solar system
so mutual contact connected our teams
about two years ago
and we've been working so hard on this
like ever since
well obviously yielded results uh this
may come as a shock to you
not to peter but i wasn't familiar with
phosphine prior to
about a week ago and so of course
i did some uh some uh googling
on the old magic box and uh this is what
came up
phosphine one is a colorless flammable
extremely toxic gas not surprising
perhaps
uh it stinks is the other thing that's
it sticks or stinks
smells like garlic can you confirm that
professor seeger is that true
well i can't confirm it for myself of
course because as you said it's toxic
we couldn't imagine just getting some
and smelling it i mean i've read that
phosphine pure pure phosphine itself is
odorless apparently but it's usually
accompanied by a contaminant that gives
it that
bad smell ah so and then the third thing
of course
is that it's formed by the action of a
strong base
or hot water on white phosphorus or
by the reaction of water with calcium
phosphide now the reason why this stuck
out
to me was if water is necessary
in its formation and we're talking i
know venus it's been
it's been theorized that there were
oceans on venus you know millions of
years ago
nobody obviously knows that but
for us here on earth we always look to
water as being that key indicator of
potential
you know life as we know it yeah um
is there any reason to believe that
these two things could be connected
because i know that right now nobody
really knows
you know as you said what's sort of
creating the phosphene right right
well i like that you picked a chemistry
example because um
also like everyone on social media is
picking their own version like chemistry
example how they think it could form
but you're right that venus doesn't have
water today so that particular mechanism
can't work
and there are other ways to form
phosphine like our
solar system planets jupiter and saturn
also have phosphine
but there they have a lot of hydrogen
because phosphine is one phosphorus atom
and three hydrogen atoms so jupiter and
saturn have not only a lot of hydrogen
but they also have
high temperatures and pressures deep in
their atmosphere where phosphine can
form
so you're right that the one you pick
doesn't work on venus i just gave you
another example that doesn't work
and two of our key team members william
baines and yanish petkowski
they did just that they worked through
every possibility and took a couple
years wrote a 100 page
tomb kind of paper on this so pretty
much everything someone could think of
we've all we've had to work through and
exclude
wow it's a lot to unpack here so it's
it's this is not a discovery of
intelligent
alien life as we would describe it but
it's still
incredibly significant uh if indeed it
turns out to be confirmed through
follow-up research
um possibly sending a probe to venus
what do you think is the most
significant part of this discovery
well it may seem a bit like boring or
low-key to you but
what we can say is you know we're
confident we found the gas phosphine
that doesn't belong in venus's
atmosphere
and on earth that gas is only associated
with life
so i think really we can't answer your
question specifically it'll take a few
years to
really understand the full impact this
is not a gas
that's just located in atmospheres it
has to be produced by a bacteria
on earth that's the case on earth right
okay well i was going to say that
you know we're left with two
possibilities that are equally
preposterous
one is that it may be arrogant to say
but that there's a chemistry we don't
know
there's something happening on the
surface or maybe the subsurface or
maybe even the atmosphere that we just
we just don't know yet
but to me that's kind of on the crazy
side but it's equally crazy that there
could be life
living in venus's clouds making this
phosphene so we really are
scratching our heads here well i'm going
to take the crazy up a notch here
because i have two
additional theories really questions
because
again you know from from an outsider's
perspective
uh when when i hear something like
uh okay there could be sort of a
microbial
life in the in the atmosphere on venus
so initially of course we look at that
we say well you know
the conditions on venus for the type of
life we know that you know it just
doesn't it doesn't add up
um but when i hear
the descriptions of earth you know
hundreds of millions billions of years
ago
i find it's somewhat similar you hear
about sort of more like
smaller microbial forms of life the
temperatures here weren't necessarily
conducive to life as we know it
different gases
different gases now over the course of
again eons that changed
and cut to you have peter and richard
sitting here is this possibly
one of two things you know us
looking in on the very beginnings of
life on venus that could
over hundreds of millions and billions
of years become what we know
or could it be the other possibility
that it used to have life as we know it
but no longer does i like your second
possibility
it has life used to have life as we know
it because we
do believe that venus did have liquid
water oceans as you said billions of
years ago
and life could have originated there
just like it did on earth
and it could have migrated to the clouds
so that when venus went through its
catastrophic runaway greenhouse it got
so hot all the oceans evaporated away
and
water got lost that uh the life
in the cloud life on the surface would
have died out because it became so hot
that life in the clouds could have
survived
and just one little thing that adding to
this story
that you may may not know about is that
our own earth has an aerial biosphere
we have bacteria that was swept that
gets swept up from our earth's surface
and it goes up into our clouds and it
lives there
in or outside of the liquid droplets for
about a week
it can be transported over continents
and then it rains back down
but our earth has transient clouds you
know they come and go whereas venus has
a permanent cloud cover
[Music]
when you talk about runaway greenhouse
effect on venus is there any sort of
parallels that you can draw to the
future of earth
it's a great question and it's a really
hard kind of homework problem we kind of
we sometimes assign to our students we
don't think our earth will go through a
runaway
no venus is much closer to the sun than
we are
and that really made a difference for
venus
because it receives a lot more heat yeah
yeah and now
it's quite possible this discovery
doesn't happen prior to
a major change in how we've come to
define life and understand life as we
know it
extremophiles so we now know that life
can exist in crazy cold temperatures
under the ocean or in crazy hot
temperatures
like in a volcano and and now apparently
in sulfuric acid
clouds on venus we've really changed our
our perception of what life can be
right well we're still trying to stretch
our minds on that one because
it's true that on earth life has defied
all of our expectations
it's been found as you said in very
extreme environments
but on venus it takes that extreme to
way new level i mean
the acid conditions in sulfuric acid
are they're way more acidic than
anything on earth
millions billions of times more acidic
well i mean there's there's obviously
i think proportionate excitement around
the world but still you know you guys
are scientists
so you're always going to be uh a little
not skeptical but you're certainly going
to be controlled enthusiasm because
there's still a lot to
uh figure out and you know prior to
follow-up missions etc
as we know science works with going back
and looking at something again
well will there be some follow-up
missions well that that will be a
question for
professor sega seeger on the other side
um we're going to
uh follow up with a few more questions
about not only the discovery
uh within the atmosphere of venus but
some other really cool stuff
uh if you don't know already professor
seger is one of the foremost experts on
exoplanets in the world so we're going
to talk about that
and a little more after the break uh so
just
sit tight professor seger we'll be back
uh with a little more on the other side
i guess you click the link below right
yeah
this is the the conclusion of our video
portion of the podcast but if you want
to get the extended audio version then
you would click on the link
uh below but if you're already listening
to the audio version then don't go
looking around for a link because there
is no link this is only for the video
portion yes so just
stand by professor seeger where can
people find your work and and follow
what you're doing
well you have two websites you can take
a look at it's one of them is
sarahseeger.com the other one is called
venuscloudlife.com and you can also
follow me on twitter
at profserisseeger.com or you can search
for me on facebook
how old is uh venuscloud.com two days
uh venus wait venuscloudlife.com correct
it's two days
venuscloudlife.com foresight
right away yes we'll do the dots here
thank you professor sega we'll talk to
you a little bit later
all right thank you so much okay well
we'll have
more with uh professor sarah seeger
later in the audio version of the show
but first richard
i want to talk a little bit more about
what
we may have found here we talk a little
bit about extremophiles
that's kind of what i think it is uh
things that can obviously live in high
temperatures
like this and we found things like
similar to
this on earth um it's not necessarily
little green men on venus that have
you know died and turned into
phosphofene gas
no i mean it's an interesting to me it's
you know
again it's a marker of where we're at
historically
uh especially as it relates to science
because i don't know how old
extremophiles are but i
i'm familiar with the word for let's say
five years maybe 10 years i thought
extremophiles were somebody who enjoys
doing
extreme sports or something yes or
extreme
x-files fans yeah yeah extremophile yeah
but i mean for those who don't know as
you said it's
it's it's it's life that can exist in in
extreme temperatures whether hot or cold
why is that important
well it's important because again we had
a very specific way we defined life
before
so then that affected how it was always
it was always something similar to us
so if it doesn't have you know the
temperature is not room temperature
and the perfect whatever life can exist
so therefore it narrows
how we look for life and where we look
for life now we
we find here on earth life existing in
the arctic
ice where we didn't think it could exist
in
volcanoes and like massive hot whatever
so now we're like oh all these planets
that we thought
couldn't host any form of life let's go
back and look at those again
and i applaud anybody like you know
professor seger in that
her early work and for those people who
don't know she's one of the foremost
people on looking at the atmospheres of
exoplanets
this was when people actually rolled
their eyes at the idea of exoplanets
existing
like within her community it was like it
seems to me it's only been the last
for for me the last 10 years or so that
people are actually believing in
exoplanets and habitable zones and
possibilities of of life in other galaxy
or another
solar system so you have her and other
people like her trailblazing
at a time where people are like ah come
on what are you looking for there's no
whatever
cut two we're in a time where not only
do we understand that you know we list
about 4 000 exoplanets
i suspect by a year from now it's going
to be
400 000 exoplanets that we think are
whether it be in
habitable zones or similar to earth or
whatever
and then you throw in extremophiles
meaning we start to look for life that
doesn't necessarily look like us
but doesn't also necessarily look like
phosphine on venus
and we might end up discovering you know
sort of star trek like that there's a
whole bunch of different ways
bipedal intelligent life can exist in a
universe
and it would start with us starting to
look at this in a different way
and i think historically people will
look back on this particular time
2020 where people are looking at you
know the this phosphine discovery in the
atmosphere of venus
as critical in terms of how we look
for life going forward yeah this is a
turning point in in our search for i
don't want to say extraterrestrial life
but i guess it is extraterrestrial life
if it ain't here it's extraterrestrial
so
what does that look like is it small is
it micro microbial is it job of the hut
i don't know
and i don't care but what i do know is
this this is significant
and it's people like sarah seeger and
jane greaves and everybody else that are
leading the way
well uh that's it for today's video
podcast but i want
you guys to all join us on next week's
uh podcast
because we continue the search for
extraterrestrial life
with uh professor andrew siemian of
seti which is our old friends at study
the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and that search continues
here on what if discussed
it does there's more with professor
sarah seeger
on the other half of what if discussed
but that's the extended audio version so
for that you'll need to click on the
link below
and that'll take you to our extended
audio cast
with more of professor sarah seeger if
you're listening to the audio podcast
right now we've had some people say
i can't find the link i can't find you
don't need the link because you're
already listening
to the audio podcast so just continue to
listen and those of you who are watching
please join us
next week and that's it for today from
what if discussed